hi I'm Ryan I'm gonna be watching the
need for speed behind-the-scenes
featurette and look singing I don't know
we played at the Super Bowl I don't
really care about this movie it it looks
ok I mean Aaron Paul is the [ __ ] yeah
mr. white what the hell man yeah he
isn't he's pretty [ __ ] cool you know
like I do stuff too Aaron Paul I don't
know why I say that about every guy
these days
hey I'm Aaron Paul and I'm Scott meskan
II need for speed is coming to a theater
near you on March 14th so if you want a
chance to win a 2015 Ford Mustang go to
race to Delhi on comm sign up and now
check out an exclusive extended look at
Need for Speed I'm gonna do that I'm
gonna go on the website [ __ ] this you
think you're a better driver than me
everyone knows he's a better driver
[Applause]
I'm willing to give six million dollars
to anyone who puts a stop to him you're
gonna have to answer for what you've
done there's an APB out for your arrest
in ten states
maybe they may want to push your eyes
for this
okay change our mind that looks pretty
[ __ ] awesome I think I actually liked
the second trailer too I just when I
thought about it early care about it but
no that looks really [ __ ] cool it's
like the really serious version of Fast
and the Furious what the first fasten
the Furious was basically